i'm like so curious about where this is
gonna go because i think this
like i you know we're in a we're in a
good spot right now right i feel like
it's in like
the middle period if you will yeah well
like everything's pretty chill
everything's all good
yeah um i i'm really interested to see
how the community in general will handle
things like all right what if a youtuber
wants to quit what if avicii
wants to be not like show their face and
just start streaming like that
yeah when these stuff because this
hasn't happened yet like can anyone do
you know of any youtubers who've been
like yeah [ __ ] do you two like big
youtubers they've been like [ __ ] this
i'm going to show my face and do normal
streams
probably the one that comes to mind is
kissing the eye uh the original one
right yeah but that's different though i
feel like i mean she wasn't
considered like a streamer like she
wasn't a youtuber yeah you're talking
about like new jobs
i'm like they're like the v is right now
right you know i mean there's been a lot
of new sanji
uh v tubers who have quit for no reason
like well i wonder if it's no reason or
you know ndas have been signed you can't
well no actually there there was one
where she openly was like i'm quitting
just because i found something else to
do
like it's nothing like i have no bad
blood or anything and i can say that
contractually
yeah i just want to quit because i have
something new to do and everybody in
that fan base took it
really really well they were like well
it's going to suck that you're going to
go but
at least all your old content is still
here right like good luck bro kind of
thing but
yeah yeah but that's good i mean
obviously at some point i can imagine
that because there's
agencies and agent scenes aren't always
the best right
there's probably going to be a messy
breakup if you will at some point right
oh i mean there has been in the past but
i mean obviously i don't want to get
into that i don't even know about it i
know all the messy breakups that have
happened yeah because of agency stuff
but
a lot of that is like it's kind of just
like well i mean it's an
agency we're dealing with and they're
you know they're trying their best to
sweep everything up
i don't even want to deal with that [ __ ]
to be honest let's not dig that stuff
yeah let's
let's not dig that stuff up it's right
like it's their problem yeah i won't ask
you know yeah because like i'm just
interested to see how the
i mean i i guess the industry grows
right it's so new right is it going to
be vtuber apology videos
if so will that be a deep sigh will they
look into the camera these are the
things i want to know like yeah i feel
like it's like
it's like re-watching youtube like
evolve but like
on like ten times speed yeah it's just
like it's
it's so it's so new and like nothing's
been defined the rules aren't set in
stone everyone's kind of doing their own
thing and it's in the wild west right
now yeah and it's
i i just love watching it and just
hearing about it and just yeah it's so
fascinating for that reason
and you know like i said i don't really
watch youtubers i watch my friends
because i'm like you know gotta gotta
support your friends
yeah yeah um and cause like one one
thing that i always think about
and one reason why i could like never be
a youtube myself is is i think about it
and
like part of part of like what i love
about being a youtuber
and making content where people know who
i am is being able to meet
fans and being able to meet people at
conventions and stuff like that and i
just think
like i just think you know especially
with conventions and
ax stuff and you know every public
meeting cancelled
last year and possibly this year as well
yeah i'm sad because
like i don't get to get the what's
what's the word i'm looking for i don't
interaction i don't get
to get the interaction because what
about that at the end of the day
like there's looking at numbers means
nothing to me
right meeting the people and meeting the
fans a lot of times it resets
like it resets like it reminds me of the
reason why i do this
and why i love doing this right like
months of stress can be like wiped out
by like one week a weekend of just
meeting fans yeah yeah
because like i don't know man it's just
like it's it's so wholesome it's like
it's a rewarding experience that you're
like it's just it's so unique
it gets it gives you something tangible
right or like the work that you've done
and i just think man
i can't imagine being a youtuber a
youtuber and just
never being able to meet fans like in
person right yeah and
and just knowing there's just so many so
many people who like love you
and what you do yeah i love everything
about you yeah i could never see it
there is like weirdly no better feeling
than just like minding your own business
going out and then someone stopping you
on the street being like i [ __ ] love
you
yeah exactly and like look because like
because i mean
well that
but i have had fan relationships like
that but like
yeah but like as a youtuber no one knows
what you look like right unless you're
or even that or like even in some
universe where you could meet fans
like they would expect you to be this
character yeah yeah
do they actually like you or do they
like this character
it's this it's a weird dynamic that i
can't imagine myself having well it's
like
i guess we appreciate that right yeah i
you know there's some youtubers
youtubers out there that are probably
like they the last thing they ever want
to do is meet anyone
right and actually i get you know yeah
yeah and i feel we can say
that you know we might not be able to
experience that and oh it's sad that
they can't experience that because
you know because we've experienced you
know fans coming up to us and liking us
and praising us
for who we are and how we show ourselves
but you know
i mean i don't know there might be some
youtubers out there who have probably
never experienced
that right so they probably don't even
know the joy yeah
of that they just think well of course
the only fan
interactions i'm going to have is people
who like my character and that's fine
[ __ ] 10
you're the same you're the same person
who like plays pokemon is like
they said peepee
no but like you know because i feel if a
youtuber went from
traditional youtubing where they get
that kind of fan experience
to then go on to v tubing and get a
completely different type of fan
experience
then sure you know there might be like
oh [ __ ] well i mean this fan interaction
is cool
but it's not the same kind of you know
gratification i got
when it was just me in front of a camera
right yeah but so a lot of these
youtubers they don't know any better
yeah so they're probably just like well
yeah of course
people like me for my character and they
probably don't give a [ __ ]
you know for me it's i feel it's the
same as you know people going up to
voice actors and actresses
and being like i love you because you
played this character yeah right
i feel it's the exact same thing it's
like well to them that's they're
probably expecting that
yeah it's it's weird because i i
obviously look at this as a con
from a content creator's perspective and
you know if i if i did ever get
the chance to give you that if i did
ever get the chance to meet any
youtubers that i really liked
i would like just wanted to say hey love
the [ __ ] content you're doing um i
also find it really fascinating
the kind of like mindset you have to be
to be this kind of content creator right
because it's such a different field from
what we're doing
and i don't know it just it just it's
just really interesting to me yeah
and just is this what it feels like when
like a parent is like
it's like i don't get this whole
youtubing thing but it must be very
difficult
i could never see myself doing it no i
mean that's why i really uh
that's why i really uh respect streamers
because they do something that i find
[ __ ] difficult to do like i i don't
know how and i'm sure it's vice versa
for the streamer
yeah i don't know i don't know how you
go home and stream sometimes come on i'm
just like
i go home i'm done i am i sleep yeah
i don't know how you go home and sleep
look at look at you you disgusting i
don't know
i just i like it it's fun i don't know i
like talking